[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah that's a tough decision because I
think we saw a different version of
banner in this film than we've never
seen before and a different version of
hope to a lot about scenes mostly were
improvised just with me and Mark Ruffalo
kind of playing around with the scenes
and same where we can push these
characters because we'd never released
spoken on camera
prior to this film well the odds we
survive this trip I'd say the odds are
about 1/2 million to find that's crazy
to think that you guys have done this
many films technically together at this
point yet this is a new pairing
all of the Avengers I think we spent so
much time together but rarely do we sit
across actual conversations together
this was an opportunity to explore just
a couple of hotheaded fools
yes Oh like fire like water kind of like
fire what point do you come into the
conversations about what they're gonna
do with the room in the movie after the
second floor now they a great time
shooting a movie but I've really felt
like I locked myself into a very
familiar territory and what was expected
from that character and I called Kevin
Feige and I said look if we're gonna do
a third one we've got a visually change
everything to change the looks you know
chosen here get rid of the hammer on the
obvious set of points um with taka the
other side vision we need to make this
different and make it something that
people don't expect and you have more
fun with it
and a lot of people have talked about
how safe Tiger made it feel for all of
you I'm set to try new things how does
he do that well the good thing you just
have a sense of who people are you know
and then do you trust them or not if
you're gonna give a director 10
different versions of the same you're
only gonna do that if you think they've
got your interests at heart and they're
gonna look after you in the Edit and I
had complete trust in him and I think
just because of the film's he'd made
prior I had a great sense of heart and
truth and humor there's a continuity now
solid collaboration and an agreement in
what we're trying to achieve
[Music]
you